all right now that we're high on paint
fumes
why couldn't they have wallpapered the
shower
ah there we go there's the backing board
come on
help me out you got this turbo
oh now i'm just destroying the wall
it's your wall not mine yeah you have to
remember that a vital part of any home
project
is uh old man swearing
god damn it
son of a
mother
all right
i wonder what conan's doing right now
what sort of gourmet
low-fat lunch he's making someone get
him
oh look at that
oh look it was pink at one time oh yeah
so that is so girly jane just told me
not to hurt myself
i was just about to hurt myself such
helpful advice
oh i hurt myself
oh i broke it
i was trying to keep it intact
here
go give that to the fedex guy
oh look at that ah yeah
oh
that is success
probably be easier
if we took the tile off the top well you
shattered that one
[Music]
hammer
yep
i mean hammer
i think
it's gonna come out in pieces
[Music]
there we go
what was that for
i don't know what did you put in there
plunger maybe it'd be a good place for a
microphone
in case you wanted to do some karaoke
let's get to no uh
incriminating spatter evidence
so usually you find that a lot in these
old homes
watch out
looking good yeah
looking real good is this what you had
in mind
no
yeah
you got to use your powers of
visualization all right but anyway uh
i'll check back after lunch
um
and i'm gonna leave you now all right
i'll be leaving with the belt all right